hair of the dog can more alcohol cure a
hangover
we've created a facility to test the
world's greatest hangover cures
and we're testing them all i'm dr keller
wortham doctor of internal medicine
i'm frank kranz i'm not a doctor but
i've been hungover
a lot welcome to the gq hangover lab
[Music]
all right what do you do brandon what
fashion stylist work with a lot of
athletes nba guys
cool shall we check this out we might as
well
what are we drinking that right there
was a double shot of whiskey
chilled uh okay wait a minute we just
went from one to
six yes how do you feel like someone
kicked me in my face
i had a cold sweat situation too our
liver's job is to make sugar for our
bodies when we're not consuming it
otherwise and if it doesn't your blood
sugar can be really low
and you get the sweats and you get the
shakes and the headache sounds like the
worst thing that's the worst thing
there's one particular
chemical that actually causes this kind
of
vasodilation in the brain and that
basically is like triggering a migraine
wow now we've ran some tests we know how
you feel
we've ran the motor skills test which i
know are very frustrating now comes the
good part we're going to
uh give you the cure uh brandon williams
he's i like him
he's cool despite his kind of charm he's
got the headache
and he had the shakes this morning now
we're gonna give him the cure
hair the dog uh we're we're gonna give
him more booze and the ultimate hair of
the dog drink we're going to give him
the bloody mary you know it's got uh
salt
it's got fluid to rehydrate you there
are a lot of antioxidants in that tomato
juice and the lime juice
vodka is a relatively clean alcohol with
not a lot of other toxins in it you're
basically gonna you know you're not
gonna get rid of the problem
you're just gonna cover it up with
something that is gonna numb you from
really perceiving the problem so
i hypothesize as well that you know
brandon's gonna feel better brandon have
a seat
all right you are a lucky man
if there was a picture in the urban
dictionary next to hair of the dog
it should be the bloody mary
was actually my first buddy mary what
what
yeah wow it's not bad either just tastes
like
alcoholic pizza sauce
[Music]
i think we've reached the limit for the
parameters of hair of the dog let's get
to it
let's see if it works the salt in the
bloody mary's
definitely pumped your blood but you're
in the 150s now
and the blood sugar is 106. oh it's
so you were at 82 before you came up to
106. 82 is like
towards the low end of normal that i'm
sure will
also make you feel better
[Music]
0.04 all right
one bounce one jack second bounce going
for two jacks
three jacks four jacks and so on
if you mess up you go back to one you've
got one minute
let's go
let's let's leave the jacks and our
pride and we'll go
sit down and put it all together i
noticed in general you were pretty laid
back about it all
i felt a lot better i feel a lot better
yeah i don't feel like i need to go to
bed or
nurse a hangover anymore so maybe it
worked one of the things
in alcohol is methanol
it breaks down into formaldehyde in the
body but your body prefers
ethanol to methanol so it's going to
break down the ethanol first and then
when you're done with that it's going to
break down the methanol and you're going
to get the nasty byproducts of methanol
if you put more ethanol in your body
it's going to go back to metabolizing
that and put the brakes
on the methanol and all the toxic stuff
it's doing to you
yep you've been you've been a great help
a great sport
thanks brandon thanks man thank you
doctor i bet you think i'm just going to
be like hey get
wasted man no i i understand like you
said it's a it's a masking cure
i'm only gonna give it a b does that
surprise you i'm such a stick in the mud
right now but the main problem is it's
just a really unhealthy habit and it can
get you into deeper problems
i would like to point out that he will
continue to get more buzz because
you can't check your blood alcohol level
right after and be like okay i'm cool
i'm going to drive because it will
continue to climb so i'm going to have
to say
um c i'm dr keller wortham i'm frank
krantz thanks for visiting the gq
hangover lab
for more tips and hangover cures
subscribe to the channel and like us
because we make damn good bloody marys